[Music]
when you become a stand-up comedian you
tell your parents I think I want to be a
comic and they're shamed of you and
that's correct and then you headline
like one or two shows and your parents
start to tell a few choice people and
then you get on TV once and they tell
freaking everybody and they want to take
credit for it like they were there
supporting instead of just 10 years of
consecutive hating my dad everywhere he
goes he's like oh my son stand-up
comedian gets a sense of humor from me
taught him everything I now I'm like dad
literally the only funny thing I've ever
seen you do is have your fly down for
the last 15 years in a row like that's
exclusively in which which admittedly is
a very funny long con we're all turned
see what to what you do with that I
realized recently get my sense of humor
from my mother here's how I realize it I
needed to know my suit jacket size I
never wear suits so I called my mom up I
was like mom I need a favor
go to my childhood bedroom go into the
closet find my old sports coat and tell
me what size of those and my mom goes
why are you buying a suit for my funeral
Jesus that's a morbid curveball mom but
that's alright I'm a ballplayer I'll
swing at that so I was just like mom I
would never wear a suit to your funeral
and she didn't even flinch she just
fired back she goes yeah cuz you could
finally wear that dress yes so I just
put on a fresh coat of lipstick went for
a long walk in the rain eventually I
fell on a sleep in the field behind a
Kohl's that's how that joke ends that's
how that joke has to learn something
interesting recently did you know the
average human being every day has up to
19 small but significant seizures and
that crazy and even though that's not
true at all just saying it out loud on
stage night after night helps me feel
better about what I think might be a
pretty serious problem that I I've just
been talking to the Walgreens pharmacist
about it we're getting nowhere I
recently had the opportunity to teach a
class on stand-up comedy kind of like
I've been doing tonight
oh it was at a school for the performing
arts and they add me in to talk about
dick jokes because that's how your tax
dollars work I don't get it I don't get
it
so for the most part I had them listen
to albums of my favorite comedians
I had him write like Dave Letterman top
ten lists so they get good at writing
punchlines and on the last day I
surprised him I brought on a mic and a
mic stand and a PA I was like guess what
you guys stand-up comedy is happening in
class today and all the 18 year old boys
in the class were like what are you
talking about dude this isn't stand-up
comedy there's like 15 people in this
room and we know everybody and I was
like yeah welcome to stand-up comedy get
used to exactly this forever and ever
and ever so they all got up there they
told their 18 year old boy bro jokes
they were terrible I hated them and then
this 14 year old girl got up to tell a
joke and she hasn't said much the entire
week she was very quiet a meek little
girl she got up to tell a joke here's
the joke that she did to put the mic in
the mic stand she cleared her throat
chewing Canadians
give him an inch they'll take 2.54
centimeters I was like what did you just
say
you are the chosen one
you've been prophesized the elders sing
songs about you I was like that jokes
incredible that jokes so good I wish I
wrote that joke can I like have that
joke
and she was like well I thought that
comedians are supposed to like write
their own material right and I was like
here's the truth of the matter you've
about four years to even allowed around
a bar to perform stand-up comedy I'm
doing Conan tomorrow I'm taking that
joke welcome to stand-up comedy
race you the TV [ __ ] those are my jokes
everybody I appreciate it
[Applause]